in the past minute the judge has decided
that he will get a whole life
sentence which will mean that wayne
cousins will go to prison
until he dies there'll be no chance of
parole
so the judge has turned down a plea from
his defence barrister jim sturman
earlier today
that uh the seriousness
of the crimes he committed were dreadful
but did not merit
the rare imposition
of a whole life sentence so the judge
has disagreed uh he's talked in the last
few minutes about police being in a
unique position and he viewed that
cousin's misuse of his police powers to
falsely arrest
kidnap abduct
rape and murder sarah everard
did merit a whole life sentence so in
the last few minutes
that's what the judge has told cousins
and and and martin the the concern about
this was whether or not he would end up
in prison for the rest of his life
whether or not it was a premeditated
murder the judge clearly concluded that
and this is all this is a man who bought
rubble bags before he carried out this
attack isn't it
yes i mean the judge has highlighted a
number of things but uh talked about the
very clear premeditation
cousins
his barrister had argued that yes he had
planned to
abduct
and rape a lone woman
the evidence for that was clear even his
own barrister admitted but he tried to
argue or he did argue
that uh there'd been no conscious plan
to
having
grabbed a victim to murder her
but the judge
has said
this morning that he had sought to
minimize his true responsibilities
for what happened the judge said he must
have realized he may well need to kill
the woman he had abducted